so today's topic is going to be
radiometric dating so let's go ahead and
get started so when we look at the
layers of rock beneath the surface we
see that you know any fossil and this
layer of rock is going to are going to
be the youngest and then any fossils in
the next layer are going to be a little
older any fossils in the next layer down
are gonna be a little older and any
fossils in the next layer down are gonna
be the oldest well this is what's called
relative dating relative to one another
we can figure out which of these samples
is the oldest than the youngest but
radiometric dating is a lot more precise
it can obtain the absolute age of a
fossil how many thousands or millions of
years old a sample might be
so to understand radiometric dating we
have to understand what isotopes are you
know carbon-12 and carbon-14 are two
very common examples of isotopes
atoms of the same element they're both
carbon but they contain a different
number of neutrons so when I look at the
carbon on the square on the top I see it
has the atomic number of six
well that means six protons anything
with six protons is going to be carbon
but the 12 is the mass and the mass is
when you add up the protons and neutrons
so six protons plus what mystery number
adds up to 12 well that's just six but
look at the square beneath it well it
has the atomic number of six again
that means six protons after all this is
still carbon and then the 14 means
protons and neutrons add up to 14 so six
plus what mystery number is 14 well
that's the number eight and so you see
the definition of isotopes they're both
the same element these are both carbon
but they have a different number of
neutrons now the reason this is
important is because carbon-14 is
radioactive and it will decay over a
period of time and we can measure the
decay to figure out how old a sample
might be
so let's focus on carbon-12 and
carbon-14 they're isotopes of carbon and
they're in the atmosphere in the form of
carbon dioxide so when plants take in
and other autotrophs when plants and
autotrophs take in the carbon to do
photosynthesis and they use the carbon
and they make glucose so when they take
in the carbon from the atmosphere
they're taken in not just carbon-12 but
also carbon-14 and that carbon whether
it's carbon-12 or carbon-14 is
transferred up the food chain when one
organism eats another it needs another
it eats another so when an organism is
alive you would expect the ratio of
carbon-12 and carbon-14 to be very
similar to that of the atmosphere after
all this carbon came from the atmosphere
but when an organism dies
start the clock the decay of carbon-14
begins
and over time carbon-14 were decay and
change and break down into nitrogen so
if something is recently dead the
remains will still possess a whole lot
of carbon-14 because not much time has
passed for it to decay but if a sample
is long dead then its remains will
possess much less carbon-14 because more
time has passed for it to decay well
let's talk about this decay
well let's talk about the time it takes
for an isotope to decay what's known as
its half-life and the half-life is the
time it takes for half or 50% of the
amount of isotope to decay and in the
example of carbon-14 it's been measured
to take about five thousand seven
hundred and thirty years for half of the
amount of carbon-14 in a sample to decay
well right now our cow is a living
organism and so it's going to have a
hundred percent of the carbon-14 that it
will ever have as it takes in a carbon
from you know eating plants as we just
mentioned on the previous slide but look
at the first layer buried underneath the
ground and this is a fossil of a horse
let's pretend that this fossil was
discovered and it has 50% of the
carbon-14 as those living today well we
would say that one half life has passed
which we know is 5730 years and so we
would say that this horse said this
fossil of the horse is 5730 years old
but look at the next fossil beneath it
let's pretend this fossil is found and
is discovered to have 25% of the
carbon-14 remaining well 25 is half of
50 and 50 is half of 100 so two
half-lives have passed since this
organism was alive so two times the
half-life of 5730 this fossil would
estimate to be about eleven thousand
four hundred and sixty years old look at
the next fossil beneath it let's pretend
this third fossil is found and
discovered and it is analyzed and it has
12 and a half percent of the carbon-14
as those alive today
well twelve and a half percent is half
of twenty-five twenty-five percent is
half of 50 and 50 percent is a half of
100 so in other words three half-lives
have passed since this thing was alive
and so we would estimate this to be
17,000 190 years old
the fourth fossil let's just repeat the
pattern let's pretend it has six point
two five percent of the carbon-14 as
those
today well that's half of twelve and a
half percent twelve and a half is half
of twenty five percent 25 percent is
half of fifty percent fifty percent is
half of a hundred percent in other words
four half-lives have passed since this
organism was living and so we would say
it's about twenty-two thousand nine
hundred and twenty years old and finally
at the bottom let's pretend this fish
fossil is analyzed and it has three
point one two five percent of the
carbon-14 well we're now up to five
half-lives of time have passed since
this was alive and so five times five
thousand seven hundred and thirty we
would estimate to be about twenty eight
thousand six hundred and fifty years old
well let's go ahead and plot this
information in a graph and what you see
in the graph is exactly what we just
talked about you can see at 50 percent
if a sample has 50% of the carbon-14
remaining it would estimate to be about
5 thousand seven hundred and thirty
years old if a sample has 25% of its
carbon-14 remaining it would estimate to
be eleven thousand four hundred and
sixty years old if a sample has 12 and a
half percent of its carbon-14 it would
estimate to be 17 thousand one hundred
and ninety years old well now this is
great for you know the the data that we
just talked about but what if there's
something that is discovered that is in
between well let's look at that what if
a fossil was found to have 70% of its
carbon-14 remaining well this is where
you can see that the beauty of a line
graph we can just kind of estimate by
drawn an imaginary line down and we
would say oh if it has 70% of its
carbon-14 remaining it would be roughly
around 3000 years old you know give or
take a few years of course what if a
sample what the fossil was found to have
20% of its carbon-14 remaining well then
if we draw an imaginary line down we
would say oh that's about 14,000 years
old so you can see with the decay rate
of carbon-14 we can roughly estimate
with pretty good accuracy the
ages of fossils you know as useful as
carbon dating might be you can see that
this graph does present a problem
eventually the amount of carbon-14
becomes so small that it's really
difficult to measure and so carbon
dating is only accurate to maybe about
fifty sixty thousand years if something
is older than that then other isotopes
have to be examined and one of those
other isotopes is potassium-40
it has a much longer half-life it's
half-life is 1.25 billion years when you
look at the graph the graph the line
looks similar as the carbon graph but
look at the time line on the bottom or
in billions of years so if a sample is
discovered to have 50% of its
potassium-40 remaining then we would
have say said that one half-life would
have passed and the sample would be
estimated to be about 1.25 billion years
old if a sample is found to have 25% of
its potassium-40 remaining then two
half-lives will have passed and the
sample will be will be estimated at two
and a half billion years old if a sample
has 12.5% of its potassium-40 remaining
then three half-lives will have passed
and the sample will have will be
estimated to be three point seven five
billion years old and if a sample has
6.25 percent of its potassium-40
remaining well then four half-lives will
have passed and the sample would
estimate to be about 5 billion years old
so as I wrap up this video it's because
of radiometric dating that we can say
the earth is four-and-a-half billion
years old and that humans have been
around for about 200,000 years because
by studying the decay of isotopes left
behind in fossils and rocks we can
accurately estimate the age of these
particular samples so I hope you found
this video helpful and thanks for
watching